welcome to pay day today with altenew
21. uh this is slowness seller speaking
and i'll be your session chair for today
uh first we go be anthony baum
uh taking us through cutting edge hyper
parameter tuning made simple with reid
too
and just a brief um
just a brief
summary of who anthony is anthony's
computer science data science and video
game reading
enthusiast and she
at heart and he holds a bsc in computer
science and econometrics and currently
student at hgh
an msc student is
if you want to know more about anthony
you can go to our
schedule
on our website uh you'll get uh his
profile and uh you'll know more there
are links in there to connect with them
after this
so at this time without further ado i
will give
the chance to you and to me to share uh
what you have with
everyone
thank you for the introduction uh so
today i'll be talking about radeon and
how it makes distributed hyper parameter
optimization simple
so just to add to who i am uh i am
mainly here as a software engineer in
any scales machine learning team but i
am also a computer science and
econometric master student and i have
been involved in various open source
projects over the years
so
what we'll be talking about today so
first i will give
a bit of background on what is ray and
what is radium
then i will talk about the challenges of
hyper parameter optimization
how those challenges can be solved
through both cutting edge hbo algorithms
and distributed hbo and how ray allows
us to use both and at the end i will
give a quick example of how to use
our sklearn wrapper for raytune
so a little bit of background on ray
what is ray
ray is a project that aims to make
distributed computing simple and
universal it has been started at the
berkeley rice lab
and then
became an open source project and since
has been developed by any scale which
aims to create a platform to provide the
best ray experience possible
over the years the project has grown
significantly right now we have over 500
users and contributors from a huge
number of companies this is just a
selection of them
what are people using gray for so for
example and is developing grey on over
200 000 cars for recommendation fraud
prediction online learning
amazon has been using great to increase
throughput of their data processing to
over one petabyte per hour while
reducing costs by over 90 percent
compared to their previous solution and
uber uses xgboost on ray and horobot on
ray for most of their machine learning
tasks
so
ray
is a library for python java and c plus
plus that provides a universal framework
for distributed computing apis and
primitives that allows
developers to easily scale up any of
their compute intensive workloads from a
single node to an entire cluster
ray can be run anywhere it can be run in
a cloud on an aws azure
google cloud it can be run on kubernetes
or it can be run
on an on-prem cluster of machines
there there are no code changes required
between running array program on a
single node or on any uh distributed
cluster
let me quickly showcase those
programming apis that i have been
talking about so here we have a simple
example of
a very uh trivial rake ray workload
ray provides both tasks and actors
tasks are the equivalent of functions
and actors are equivalent of classes
tasks are stateless and actors are
stateful
we can very easily turn a python
function to array task by using the ray
remote decorator
and
this is not showcased in the example but
it is also possible to specify various
resource requirements that our task or
actor will
require during its operation and
thanks to that
it will be able to take advantage of
resource our scheduling that ray uses
now that we have
our task we can invoke it using the
remote method
which will immediately return an object
reference or a future in other words
and it will create a task that will be
executed on array cluster that we are
connected to
then we can use ray get to
receive the result of that task
and it is important to note that calling
a remote task or a method of a remote
actor does not block
so in the second part of the example
we execute slow function uh
four times in parallel it will the tasks
will be scheduled on the cluster and we
can return
the results once the computation has
been complete
so
based on those apis and those primitives
ray has
as a project has developed
several libraries providing support for
different machine learning use cases
for example we have ray hgd and to be
renamed to raytune that allows for deep
learning training on a cluster we have
rlip one of the
most advanced and extensive
reinforcement learning libraries
and we also have created race surf which
takes care of models serving at a scale
on this talk we'll be focusing on tune
which handles hyper parameter tuning
so raytheon
is our solution for distributed hyper
parameter optimization
it provides efficient cutting-edge hbo
algorithms and it distributes and
coordinates parallel trials in a fault
tolerant and elastic manner
because raytheon is running on ray it
can take advantage of ray features such
as auto scaling which means that it can
request
new nodes to be added as
resource
requirements increase
and it can also bring down nodes
once they are not necessary anymore
thanks to all of those features
as well as
overall simplicity uh radion saves
you time and costs every step of hyper
parameter optimization
so this is a benchmark that uber has run
on over two weeks of production data and
compared to their previous in-house
solution
ray has allowed for over two times
efficiency improvement in terms of gpu
and cpu hours
uh but before we can uh truly talk about
how raytune makes hyper parameter
optimization simple we should first set
some context about what hyper parameters
and hyper parameter optimization or
tuning is
so this will be just a brief
introduction for those who may not be
familiar with the term
when we have a machine learning model
it learns a set of parameters during
training but there are also
such parameters that are set before
training and we call those hyper
parameters for example this may be the
number of trees in an xgboost model
or it can be the number of layers and
the kind of layers
and the kind of the number of neurons in
a layer in a deep learning model
with more complex models the number of
hyper parameters can grow to very can
grow very large resulting in very
complex and very diverse search spaces
furthermore it is possible to go one
step beyond and not only consider the
hyper parameters of a model itself but
also consider the hyper parameters of an
entire data processing pipeline with an
estimator at the end
or even
consider the choice of the steps in a
pipeline as a hyper parameter itself
here is a simple example of a pipeline
of an xg post at the end
and an imputer a categorical encoder and
under over sampler for imbalanced data
as you can see the choice of
of all of those steps
and the choice of hyper parameters for
each of those steps
results in a very large
hyper parameter search space which can
be challenging to evaluate on a single
note efficiently
hpo is the main challenge of hyper
parameter optimization is that it's very
time consuming because the only way we
can learn whether the
selected combination of hyper parameters
gives a good result is by fitting the
model and that can take seconds but that
can also take days depending on the use
case
there is also a large number of
combinations that we have to evaluate
before we can find such combinations
that give good results
on the other hand
we can turn to parallel computing
for reducing the time needed but that
will incur additional costs in terms of
compute
how can raytheon help with reducing that
cost and time raytune provides efficient
algorithms that minimize the time
necessary to find
such combinations of hyper parameters
that give good results
and it efficiently orchestrates
running or the distributed trials on a
cluster and finally it provides easy to
use apis
furthermore the same co the same rating
code can be run on both a single node
or on a cluster
and because it is possible for the user
to specify their own objective function
it is virtually
compatible with every machine learning
library
so what sort of algorithm is is raytune
uh providing
we have over 15 algorithms that are
natively provided or integrated from
other libraries and it is easy to swap
them out with minimal code changes
let me give you a quick tour
so the the simplest way to evaluate
hyper parameters is to use exhaustive
also known as grid or random search
in terms of grid search we simply try
out every possible combination of hyper
parameters
and in terms of random search we just
sample the hyper parameter distributions
randomly and because every trial is
independent from each other it's very
easy to parallelize and easy to
implement
but
most of the times it is quite
inefficient and compute intensive as the
information from the previous trials is
not used
for choosing the combination the next
trial
here we can turn to bayesian
optimization
which
in its simplest explanation uses the
results the information from previous
evaluated trials to decide which trial
to try next
this usually involves
fitting a surrogate function and using
that
to choose
the next combination to trial
to try
bayesian optimization is inherently
sequential because it requires the
information from previous trials however
there have been seen some advances
that allow
parallelization of different types of
vision optimization some popular
libraries
that implement bayesian optimization are
hyper opt optional psychic optimized and
never groud and there are of course many
more all of those libraries here have
been integrated into radio
aside from choosing what configurations
to evaluate
we can also improve efficiency of our
tuning by
using advanced scheduling
this means that we use the intermediate
results of a trial such as epochs trees
or samples to prune underperforming
trials
saving time and computing resources
there are various algorithms for that
such as median stopping hyperbond or
asha
and they can be sometimes combined with
bayesian optimization
the figure here showcases uh these
successive halving algorithm
where in each rung uh half of the worst
performing trials are terminated and the
other half is led to run until their
resources are exhausted
in
practical terms that would mean that
more combinations can be tried without
having to evaluate them fully
another type of advanced scheduling is
population based training it is
mainly intended for schedule parameters
such as learning rate in deep
in neural networks
and
we evaluate a population in parallel
terminate lowest performers and then
copy the weights of best performing
trials and mutate them this is a type of
an evolutionary algorithm and it can be
quite tricky to implement on your own
thankfully raytune provides an
implementation
there are also some other advanced
sampling algorithms that have been
integrated into retune such as blend
search which takes into account
the execution time of each combination
and progressively trying more expensive
combinations so for example it may try
with very small xg boost models composed
of only a couple of trees and
progressively move to bigger models
which take more time to evaluate
we also provide an integration with
heteroskedastic evolutionary bayesian
optimization which combine combines
bayesian optimization with evolutionary
algorithms
this algorithm has won the
newer ips 2020 black box optimization
competition
and we provide an integration for bohb
which combines bayesian optimization of
hyperbond
meaning it can make informed decision
based on partial results and terminate
underperforming trials
so
let's review what we have talked about
so far
there are various hpo algorithms and
there is a huge trend of going parallel
as the evaluation times of models
increase
more advanced algorithms are often hard
to implement and even more so in a
distributed setting
all of the different libraries that
implement those hbo algorithms have
their different apis and different
functionality
however raytheon implements and
integrates with all of those algorithms
and their parent libraries and it also
allows you to bring your own algorithms
it allows the user to swap out different
algorithms very easily and take benefit
from a unified api
now that we know what sort of
requirements
hbo algorithms may have
we can think about
what sort of architecture we will
require in order to efficiently
contact distributed hyper parameter
optimization
so we definitely require granular
control over when to start pulse early
stop and restore or mutate each trial at
specific iterations with little overhead
we require a master worker architecture
that centralized decision making so that
the orchestrator has access to the
information from all the trials
we have a sampler which provides
combinations to evaluate and a scheduler
that decides which trials to stop start
and pause
and since we are talking about the
distributed hyperparameter optimization
we need to have elasticity and fault
tolerance
so how does ray tune implement all of
those architecture requirements first
the user provides their own training
function
this can be any
calculation using any machine learning
library
by using tuner report
the metrics are reported back to the
orchestrator
which
launches worker processes those worker
processes each have one trial and one
trial corresponds to one combination of
hyper parameters because we are running
this in a distributed setting those
worker processes can be scheduled on
both the head node and worker node as a
resources permit
the worker processes report back metrics
to the orchestrator which keeps track of
all of the trials progress
and based on those metrics the
orchestrator
may stop pause or mutate trials and it
can launch new trials when resources
become available in other terms when one
of the worker processes terminates
furthermore
in order to provide fault tolerance the
orchestrator also manages checkpoint
state
and in case one of the worker processes
crashes the orchestrator can load the
checkpoint from cloud storage and
restore
[Music]
the training from back when it stopped
so let's quickly review what we have
talked about what makes ray tune special
first it provides various types of
efficient hbo algorithms
and it distributes and coordinates
parallel trials in a fault tolerant and
elastic manner
it is well integrated with the ml
ecosystem
so
as i have mentioned before it is the
user has to create their own training
function however in order to simplify
things and
with how popular psychic learning apis
are and for a good reason they are very
easy and pleasant to use we have created
a scikit-learn wrapper for ratio
we wanted it to be a drop in replacement
for the scikit-learn model selections
module which provides randomized search
cv and greaser
cv
and we wanted to provide a familiar and
simple api for advanced distributed hbo
and here is our project page
so this is an example of
how we would use
scikit-learn model selection with
grid search cross-validation
and
the
one thing about scikit-learn
implementations is that they can only be
run on a single machine
however by using tune sklearn it is
possible to just with two lines of code
changed
harness the power of an entire raid
cluster and use all of the resources
available throughout the entire cluster
furthermore tune search cv allows you to
choose
all of the different optimizations
algorithms and schedulers present and
in radio
and it allows you to
specify the resource requirements for
your models
so here is a quick demo
of how tuna scaler can be used we are
using a driver safety prediction data
set which has around 600 000 rows
and 50 columns
it uses a cluster that has been started
before through ray cluster launcher
which composes five nodes each with
eight cpus
and we are using a jupiter notebook that
runs on the head node
so
first
we will connect
to our ray cluster
by using gray in it
and we can see how many cpu resources we
have
this is the scikit-learn code randomized
search cv but we can very easily
turn it
into
tune search cv we replace the uh
sci-pi distributions with tuned
distributions for hyper parameters
and we simply replace
random randomized search cv with two
search cv
and we can choose how many
trials we want to run in parallel and we
can also take advantage of early
stopping as described before
and just like that and we get our result
and we can access the entire history of
optimization
through the analysis object returned by
tune search cv
and we can also
plot the
cumulative maximum score over time
finally we disconnect from the array
cluster
uh thank you this concludes my talk uh
let's keep in touch uh here are some
links to our to raid website our
discussion forum and our slack
and to
the github page for tune sklearn
i am happy to take any questions you
might have now
thank you so much anthony
uh here we have a question from
um i don't know if i'm going to
pronounce your name correctly and at all
so anatol asks do you provide classical
parameter grids for most popular
algorithms
we
do not do that however
there is a project that is
being conducted right now that
eventually aims to allow
for us to suggest
which combination of
search algorithms and parameter grids
would be most suitable for a given task
however this will probably take some
time before it is complete that being
said there are many
auto email libraries that are based on
raytune or have support for retune like
ludwig
which provide
pre-made parameter grids
okay thank you so much
um i think we have another question here
oh it says uh how does rey work together
with ml flow
i see certain overlap but not fully
yes but not fully
right so
ray by itself only provides
apis and primitives for other
libraries to be built upon however
raytune
has an integration of ml flow a callback
that reports the results to ml flow so
you can
maintain a unified history of the
optimization of mlflow we also support
weights and biases we also support
tensorboard and it is possible for you
to write your own callbacks for any
bookkeeping solution you may require
okay um i hope video uh got his uh his
or her answer
um we have another question from v
we asked uh she's uh v says i use
darkerized trainers and v and dvc
metrics how hot do you think will be
integrating to ray
um
that's a very good question uh i would
have to
uh
i would have to probably answer that
offline once i know more about your use
case so let's connect on slack if
possible
okay we i hope you heard that uh we'll
get your uh answer on slag
and uh nick asks uh if a single machine
with multiple cars or gp gpus is
powerful enough does ray offer any
advantage
or it is mainly for setting where you
need it faster
so
uh radeon provides a unified api for
various different search algorithms
which allows you to easily
see
which one is the best for your use case
and at least compared to scikit-learn it
allows you to specify resource
requirements for each trial
with a huge degree of flexibility
as as far as i understand scikit-learn
doesn't really support
gpu gpu training however with raytune it
is possible for you to define how many
gpus each trial should use and
that will ensure that the trials
run without any slowdowns or
interruptions
okay if there are no more further
questions i think we've come to the end
of uh your talk
and i'm certain that um all those who
attended have really learned a lot and
just a reminder to everyone attending um
this recording will be available
on our youtube channel and we also have
slack in case uh you can't ask anything
now but you want to connect with anthony
later you can get his profile from our
website and connect with him on github
and linkedin
ah thank you so much anthony
thank you all
you